عندما تسمع احد يكيل السباب للاخر قد
تعتقد انه عصبي او يعاني من ضغوط نفسيا
مثلا لكن وفق خبراء في علم الادراك
والسلوك فان هذا الشخص اكثر راحه نفسيه بل
يستخدم طريقه بديله عن العنف الجسدي
ادريسه الامريكيه مشاهدين التي نتحدث عنها
اليوم تشير الى جانب غريب من الشتائم وهو
ان لها
بالفوائد ليس فقط في تهدئه الاعصاب بل
ايضا تمنح القدره على تحمل الالم ايضا
الباحثون ذكروا في دراساتهم كلمات الكاتب
الامريكي الساخر مارك توين الذي كان على
صواب عندما قال انه في ظل ظروف معينه يمكن
ان توفر الالفاظ البذيئه الراحه
بالفعل الشتيمه الواحد لما بيقولها فئه عن
نوتها او في سياقها او لما تكون رد فعل
الموقف ضاغط على الانسان بتبقى شكل من
اشكال التنفيس الانفعالي بتعمل ازاحه
للمكبوتات فاحيان كتير الانسان فينا لما
بيجي يشتم حد مش بيشتمه انما هو بيوصفه في
لفظ معين بيجسد كل معانيه في السلوكيات
والغير مرغوبه وبالتالي حتى بتخاف من وضعه
السلوك العدواني يعني بدل ما يعمل رد فعل
عدواني فبيكتفي بالشتيمه او ينعته بلفظه
او اتنين ومش شرط على فكره الشتيمه تبقى
في المواجهه يعني ممكن انا يحصل لي موقف
ضاغط فنوع من السوشيال اكشن او التكيف
الاجتماعي مع الذات احكي لحد في مكالمه
تليفون او في حديث مرسل بيني وبينه وانعد
حد بلفظ غير مرغوب فالشتيمه احيان كثير
بتدي نوع من التكيف ازاحه المكبوتات رفع
الضغوط بتديك شعور بالكفاءه النفسيه وفي
احيان كتير كمان احنا بنشتم كنوع من
التغلب على بعض المخاوف المرضيه يمكن حتى
كان فيه برنامج للمقالب شهير جدا في رمضان
كنا بنشوف الضيوف اول حاجه يعملوها كانوا
يتوجهوا بالشتائم اللي كان بيستضيفهم ليه
بيتغلبوا على مخاوفهم المرضيه بلس ان
التقرير اشار لحته مهمه جدا ان هي بتزيد
من قوه الانسان في مواجهه الالم نتيجه ان
الواحد لما بيجي يشتم بيرتفع عنده
الادرينالين بيتراجع الدوبامين وبناء عليه
بيبقى عنده قوه
بتختلف عن اقراننا عاديين اللي هم ممكن ما
بيشتموش
من المؤامره النفسيه للانسان هل الموضوع
بيختلف وهذه الدراسه بما انها دراسه
امريكيه قد لا تنطبق على مجتمعاتنا
العربيه
ام انه هي طبيعه انسانيه يعني خلينا نتفق
احنا بنقيد الدراسه بنقيد نتائج الدراسه
مش من ايد الشتيمه يعني تاييدنا النتائج
الدراسه من الناحيه العلميه لا يعني ان هي
تبقى دعوه لاطلاق السباب والقذائف
بالمناسبه الشتيمه مش في كل الاحيان
بتعني ان انا بقول الفاظ اخلاقيه غير
اخلاقيه هي ممكن تقول الفاظ غير مرغوبه
واحد نمره اتنين حضرتك الانترنت دلوقتي
بقى له لغه خاصه في الشتائم يعني لغه خاصه
كده فرانكو عرب بيستعينوا بها الشباب وهم
بيكتبوا على الشات فمقدرش نتجاهل الظاهره
ودي مهمه بس مش معنى كده اللي احنا نخليها
على المشاعر لسبب بسيط جدا لان الانسان لو
قعد يشتم على طول هنا هيوشار اليه ببعض
الصفات الغير مرغوبه قد يعرض للتجنب
الاجتماعي فاحيانا كثير ممكن يفقد المركز
الوظيفي بتاعه
[موسيقى]